bueno en realidad creo que el problema
de este gabinete no es tanto el
nombramiento de aníbal torres sino a
quien se pudo haber nombrado y no se
nombró y se sacó del gabinete y me
refiero al ministro de salud el señor
zevallos que a
ha sido el único éxito indiscutible que
ha tenido este gobierno hasta este
momento que es la vacunación
más de 20 millones de peruanos tienen
dos vacunas y por lo tanto la protección
contra una muerte por este por este
virus y este del bien sus ojos y va a
ser el primer ministro pero trascendió
que como de conformidad con la
constitución al primer ministro le
corresponde proponer lo siguiente a los
demás ministros el presidente no habría
aceptado estas propuestas y pretendían
nombrar ministros de su preferencia
entonces el perú ahora tiene al
ministro al primer ministro vázquez y
además ha prescindido de él el director
de esta gestión exitosa en materia de
salud y la polémica se refiere bueno
porque hay una especie de lenguaje
estridente que emplea veces el ministro
torres pero creo que eso está en la
anécdota para mí lo más importante es
que el perú el gobierno ha prescindido
ministro que estaba llevando a la
gestión del problema más importante del
país y de muchos países en este momento
que es el entrenamiento enfrentamiento
de la pandemia en su reemplazo se han
nombrado a un a un a una persona que
tiene en investigaciones por corrupción
y además el señalamiento de
promover bebidas este pseudo científicas
entonces este el problema creo que es
mucho más grave que el temperamento del
señor torres viene desde su perspectiva
este cuarto gabinete traerá estabilidad
para el gobierno del castillo
ojalá ojalá la inestabilidad tiene como
tiene como raíz el hecho de que
generalmente cuando se programa un
presidente y si este juramento hay un
mes de distancia y ahí se preparan los
equipos en este caso no pasó así porque
la oposición el partido perdedor demoró
en reconocer los resultados impugnó y
sólo pudo ser proclamado el presente
castillo días antes de juramentar esa es
la razón por la cual no tuvo equipo
parado
presentó un gabinete que fue
improvisado y el primero así como los
otros tres y este esperamos esperemos
que no sea que no ocurre lo mismo y que
crea alguna estaba inestabilidad lo
preocupante es creo el sector salud
señor omar cairo en roldán a usted
gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo en france24